all month long advocates are raising
awareness about heart health we continue
to navigate the pandemic unfortunately
we're learning more also about how cova
19 impacts the entire body bianca holman
is sharing the district the health
district and what it's doing to help
patients
good morning so helping people reduce
the risk of heart disease that's what
the southern nevada health district is
doing all month long and also there's
another factor that now people are
thinking about when it comes to heart
disease coven 19 there is an impact on
your body
again we're learning about more symptoms
that happen to people later on after
they have recovered so to maintain a
healthy heart doctors recommend a
healthy diet meaning low sodium limit
foods with trans fat manage any other
health conditions you may have like high
blood pressure or diabetes and know the
signs of a heart attack heavy chest pain
cold sweats and dizziness many health
providers are seeing an increase in
patients with high blood pressure
because of increased stress of the
pandemic and missed doctor's
appointments over the past two years
cardiologist we spoke with from umc
tells us that covet increases
inflammation in the body which can cause
clotting
it caused the
inflammatory changes in the heart we
call the myocarditis
and pericarditis and sometimes it
mimicked heart attack and sometimes with
the higher
clotting tendency did give heart attack
so in many ways it affected the heart
so the cardiologist we spoke to says
detection and intervention early on can
help prevent
worst case scenario so the health
district has a variety of free classes
and events all month long there's blood
pressure monitoring programs a youth
cooking class and diabetes management
classes several others several things
that they're doing across the community
to help raise awareness and help people
recognize those risk factors and
decrease those risk factors ultimately
improving their heart health coming up
in the next half hour we're going to
talk about heart health and women
bianca holman live local now